[Music]
I like this that's chances of rapper
showing off his dance moves with the
Backstreet Boys and the Doritos
Superbowl commercial this year tens of
thousands of people rated their favorite
ads on USA TODAY's Ad Meter and first on
CBS this morning we're revealing the top
rated Superbowl commercials number three
is the commercial for Microsoft
featuring children with disabilities
using accessible controllers for video
games now everyone can play universally
alright that's that one that's that
button that's that button perfect number
two is the ad for Amazon's Alexa
featuring products it did not make we
made an Alexa job caller for dogs
ordering dog food ordering dog you can
bar call you one I'm not paying for any
more dog food
everyone rated Super Bowl at is the NFL
commercial celebrating the league's
upcoming 100th season oh boy
[Music]
no can do cowboy today's national
business correspondent joins us at the
table to discuss hey Charisse why did
these three stand out for you I think
that the top adds touch either the
heartstrings or the funny bone they make
an emotional appeal and that NFL ad was
just so great it was this really kind of
energetic tribute to the lead and if you
were a fan it was like the ultimate
fantasy so everybody everybody and then
there's bedlam that ensues and they even
make a nod to women in football they got
a 49 year old girl at the board and so
it was just really funny and energetic
and a lot of people think it had a lot
more energy than the actual game I loved
Serena's ad did that rate well for
Bumble middle of the pack but it really
Illustrated a theme we saw this year of
women's empowerment you know and she
embodies that yes of race and gender and
motherhood in the issue she talks about
Toyota did the same thing with
Antoinette Harris who wants to be the
first female player in the NFL so that
was really a refreshing trend that we
saw this year that was new and it seems
strategic I know the bumble CEO said she
wanted to have this ad run during the
Superbowl to appeal not only to women
but to men as well right and it makes
sense I mean half the audience for the
game is female but obviously men care
about women's empowerment too and I
think that was really a dominant theme
that people appreciate it and we also
had cameos from stars for example the
Stella Artois and let's let's take a
look at that rate that ad which air give
me a Stella Arcos
excuse me
rejoice Wow changing can do a little
good bridges what why did that add
resonate because there are two iconic
characters that we all know they're
known for their signature drinks and
they're basically giving them up for a
good cause right if you buy Stella
Artois they're gonna donate clean
drinking water for a month so I was
using familiar characters to talk about
a good deed that the company is doing
and people just love seeing them
together any clunkers
yeah the Burger King commercial didn't
do too well with Andy Warhol they just
went right over people's I didn't get it
there many young people may not know
exactly I think it was a little bit too
esoteric I mean the whopper was the
centerpiece I mean your product was
there but I think a lot of people just
didn't get it and there were a lot of
robots this year a lot of Technology and
the TurboTax commercial with the Robo
kid I think was a little bit creepy to
people so that came out near the bottom
as well and if you run your ad earlier
do you have to pay more are they all the
same often wonder about the the timing
either timing of how it works because
Serena's ad was near the front where and
I think more people are paying attention
does it matter when you run it in terms
of cost it doesn't it's about it's more
than five million dollars for thirty
seconds of airtime very becoming first
or at the end probably makes more sense
in terms of having more eyeballs on you
the biggest surprise the night came from
the Bud Light Game of Thrones ad let's
take a quick look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
and I love Game of Thrones but why did
this make Twitter go crazy I think it
was a really unexpected tie-in I mean
you didn't expect to see the game of
Thrones in a bud light they're known for
what Billy Billy and all of that and so
it was just really fun and if you're a
fan and they have a lot of them people
really love that component rees-jones
thank you always good to have you here
thank you so much and you can see more
Super Bowl commercials and the results
of USA TODAY's Ad Meter at CBS news.com
slash ads